bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ci siamo tornati su
aver chiesto quando si è perso ma no
quella è quella e gualdo novaled è però
ci siamo vicini con crea dice
abbandonata
siamo rimasti qui perfetto ben è
bellissimo la partenza è stata
fantastica ma perché c'è tipo la perla
nera con jack sparrow non lo so c'è una
nave vale io salgo a caso non si sa come
ci siamo arrivava bene va bene così non
facciamoci noman ragazzi ok al gargano
nello scorso episodio ho già visto di
tutto quindi va bene così o sfidare la
nave no perfetto sarebbe stato troppo
bello per essere vero tipo però che
cos'è c'è una c un cannone che punta un
legno devo portare sta roba di sotto sto
meglio quando ti prendi in mano furgoni
sono morto no che cazzo questo cadendo
chiesto ragazzi
ok ok ok è un gioco della madonna
c'erano tipo dei tizi bellissimi che
fluttuavano fantastico bonus rinchiuso
gioco reati da dietro ne va beh va a fan
culo umbria si diceva l'obiettivo che è
l'obiettivo principale
ho capito che puoi sentire una donna
gridare a me ne frega una sega tanto non
è mia io posso soltanto mar una donna
nella mia vita darà la gamba quella
scorsa facciamo cinema
l'odore di morte era nell'aria no quella
sono i tuoi piedi wilden non ci aveva
fatto caso la mia gamba
lo trovate ragazzi la vendetta la paura
erano soltanto gli unici sensi del dl
cacciatori fa piacere prendo ritrovare
la mia gamba quindi me ne frega una sega
dei sensi
ok ora fatemi pandemia fucile perché
sono qua finisco male la mia gamba era
vera non era così male inizia non fare
un razzista
non costa donna che urla ma basta per me
è solo ciò che siamo tipo data center
giochi e giocattoli però devo capire un
attimo dove il rapporto casse e questo
gli ha detto no no no no no no no no no
no no no non lo è chiuso è chiuso non
era chiuso prima non ha chiuso [ __ ]
tutto grazie alla grande quaderno agli
uomini forti e vigorosi che non abbiamo
paura di niente
farid ghadry adesso posso farlo lontano
col barile forse non lo so non lo saprò
di muoversi è morto è morto dopo l'altro
e cazzo c'è ancora l'altro c'è ancora
l'altro una sega è che cosa ha fatto
quel barile è quanto god oria non c'è
proprio verso che schifo gesky a [ __ ]
scala cup e carle sono troppo piccoli
tipo che però non ho più colpi adesso
quindi niente più ragni qualcosa al
shaila ridere tutti adesso mori
compagnia di tre gare non fa niente
andiamo avanti lo stesso che siamo forti
c'è la mamma che proprio boots e cerca
in consigliate sti giochi ma basta basta
che rompimento di farle però ragazzi
madonna che a cazzo ti ha fatto quel
barile ok ok calmissimi ragazzi
calmissimi che ce la facciamo ciò 14
colpi una calma mentale incredibile ah
ok morto è morto peace and love è morto
basta basta voglio andare voglio uscire
in qua fatemi uscire mi sembra il
momento di suonare la chitarra che sto
morendo l'infarto lurido che cazzo di
suoni che sto io non vivo per miracolo
non lo so che cosa l'inaspettato è
successo si si sono spuntati nei bagni
grossi così ecco cosa è successo di the
dungeon ancora almeno cambiate nemici
cazzo due mete vedete che ne so they dei
topi qualcosa mi dice di no vabbè altri
proiettili che bello conoscere i
proiettili a terra che vuol dire che
devo fare
la terza guerra mondiale che sta
succedendo no no no no no no no non ho
mai non entrò come neanche se mi paiono
oro non avete capito una sega ragazzi
possiamo proposto seriamente incazzarmi
s'è chiuso muro
no no no no no no no no no no non se
esce qualcosa giorno in cazzottone di
enna
no no no
no non ci stiamo capendo no no no no no
no no no mi sento male
giuro non avete capito un cazzo stai
fermo ma perché ma quanti siete cazzo a
morire male e ve lo diciamo sì è morto
per benefico che sono la chitarra con su
se normale no ma sia saltato dei ragni
giganteschi mi stanno attaccando non è
mai niente non muoiono porca [ __ ]
ok madonna che mira di merda però è
morto lo stesso cos'è sta roba
non me ne frega niente poi ci salgo
sopra bene così bene così quanto sei
figo ti togli ti dico grazie
[Applauso]
se c'è un'altra merda coi ragni o spengo
quale gli annunci a sentirti cos'è
colline colline bianche fantastico
quanto so già che mi deve incazzare
quindi non c'è bisogno se quella roba lì
è un pianoforte è una croce ma cos'è sta
roba sotto alle catacombe lenton sembra
un pianoforte ma allora sentite mi va
bene qualsiasi [ __ ] cosa ma non iran
o bisogno di trovare una chiave capito
proprio che questa roba
basta ragni pastorali e che cazzo rotto
i [ __ ] che non bastavano in one gli
scheletri nome di ragni ragni propri
ranghi devono mettere quelli lo sapevano
di cio che vostra merda lo sapevano
sempre meglio proprio no tomba del cazzo
ho trovato un pezzo di a ok ok cambio
non trovereste robe sulle tombe in poche
parti però un casino mio dio ne mancano
due mancano cioè mentre questi si
perfetto da me ne mancano due ragazzi
dovrebbe essere qui se non sono mi
sbaglio credo si sia perfetto meno anche
uno che mi dà senso a peccare quello di
home io sono la persona più felice del
mondo prega mi incazzo esami spunterà
non l'ho preso e però ci saranno sì sì
sì ok io presi tutti i pezzi anche
ammazzato tutti tra l'altro non sono
anche come ho fatto
prova va bene così basta che anche chi
entrò ma dentro che non ne posso più
grazie a dio e che impianti ha ammesso
diventato verde non so perché ma va bene
così faccio questo e basta perché non ne
posso più che cosa ci faccio pubblico
sotto vieni a sentire il potere della
della mia oscurità chi è questo che
parla è un cane se vuoi ti ad 80 è non è
un problema perché credo che sia il boss
finale questo però non vorrei dire cose
che poi non sono quelle credo e non lo
so
daniel shea zio bobby fantasma zero come
sai io 6 ma il bello di conto mi
ricordassi fatemi andare avanti bello
show di teschio dio mi ha almeno questo
è una consolazione cos'è sei tornato
morirai
ma [ __ ] non sai cosa passato l'ho
preso
non ho preparato talenti che cazzo è
successo è sarti po tutti gli amici e
cazzo sono tipo a tutti gli amici quindi
credo che ci saranno anche i ragni cazzo
sentita bastardo ma che me l'ha fatta
già fatto ragazzi sto stronzo è
fortissimo ok è la madonna cos'è sta
roba
dove non vedo un cazzo l'ho preso l'ho
preso preso perfetto sentite un attimo
come cazzo sono ste cose che mi bilancio
siamo tipo cervelli enormi che palle che
giornata di merda si è già fatta già
fatta [ __ ] fund ha visto che
adesso non mi travasare in marocco basso
e basta piace quando sai che bello
quando ci metterà in fasi nelle cose che
mi stanno sul cazzo 7 insignificante
creatura sei veramente una persona morto
ore di gioco insulso per vedermi morire
così mister prendo pericolosa pirotto è
stato distrutto da una misteriosa da un
misterioso s ragazzi che cazzo succede
ma è morto da solo da che la forse la
cercando una pergamena nascosta dentro
le dentro le mura delle catacombe
ragazzi però la musica mi sta dando
mi fucka leggermente cagasotto se
permettete ed è praticamente ragazzi a
su ho finito
va bene così un finale degno di rafael
cappellini che ancora non ho capito
perché ti chiami i capelli in cui agazzi
la morale di tutto questo è can che
abbaia rompe il cazzo come ora comunque
devo dire che è stato è estremamente
nonsense mah vabbè tanto ho giocato
giocato a rob è molto più senso di
questa mini non mi stupisco neanche più
i ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma solito
stato commento mi piace anche a faccia
di facebook e come ogni minuto natale
iscrizione a prestiti schiacciatrici
diventiamo un po sorrido belle ragazze